a remarkable story of a bus drivers
heroism emerged from the devastating
fire in Paradise California photos taken
from inside a school bus filled with
children show their harrowing journey as
the camp fire rages just feet away but
the pictures tell only part of that
story DeMarco Morgan shows us where the
bus faced some of the biggest dangers on
its escape from paradise DeMarco good
morning good morning to you the bus
driver was left with no other choice but
to stop that bus here along a kneel road
and basically wait for traffic to clear
all along while flames are on both sides
of the highway you can take a look at
this car right here and look at the
burned-out vehicles as proof and even
though Kevin McKay's family had
evacuated he knew he had one more job to
complete I just knew that things were
gonna continue to escalate were you
scared
yeah frightened absolutely school bus
driver Kevin McKay took this picture the
morning of November 8th responding to an
emergency call he went to Ponderosa
Elementary picked up 22 students and
drove them away from the fast-moving
fire some McDonald's was on the left
that was on fire
to the right of us one of the evacuation
sites was the CMA Church all the trees
behind the church are on fire
Kevin Towe teachers Abby Davis and
married Ludwig to comfort and distract
the student but ignoring the flames was
impossible for 7 year old Wendy Reeves
someone I held back from crying the
entire time but I we were so focused on
those kids and that great responsibility
is what really kept us focused but a
smoke turned to the sky tonight it began
to fill the bus some of the children
said they felt tired and nauseous
quick thinking let Kevin to pull off his
shirt the woman toured into pieces
doused them with water and show the kids
how it could help them breathe we were
coughing and my eyes were or hurt and I
knew we had to do something and that was
you know our best option with what we
had there's smoke coming in a little bit
but they gave us like rags to put
mariette a be admitted faith feared for
their lives we were both trying to keep
each other from crying and we just kind
of held hands and we just said a prayer
kevin drove for five hours with the
traffic often at a standstill and smoke
obscuring his view but he delivered the
children to safety some 30 miles away we
didn't leave tell every kid was
accounted for and every kid was with
their mom and dad well some called kevin
a hero he says there were others that
day who did much more our firemen worked
on the opposite direction we were mm-hmm
and that's pretty awesome that Kevin and
Wendy both lost their homes and Wendy
said she also lost her pets but there is
some good news out here Wendy celebrated
her eighth birthday alive and well John
tamargo thank you and thank you for
bringing us that story